[Musique]
la belle les positions c'est jérémy
jamais comme je vous aime la scène sur
fond si monsieur l'abbé ici mais c'est
vrai que je vous aime beaucoup mais là
il a même repris qu'il avait embrassé
bon à savoir
[Applaudissements]
mais
karam a alors elle n'est pas marrant je
la comprends je suis lavé les dents
allez je peux regarder juste te rassures
toi lui non plus n'ont malaisie ah mon
dieu je tape à dakota bon à lakota à
dakota non je sache mac au moins ça va
alain cotta
[Applaudissements]
joli jeu qui fait j'ai kiffé et
franchement le d'anti n'est pas gênant
[Applaudissements]
et recommence je leur passe non mais
vous savez je me suis dis toujours que
je lui dis horloge à chaque fois d'où ce
jour là je lui dit isabelle vous êtes
magnifique et elle m'a dit non non non
elle est très belle et tu le fais alors
arrête toi non jours à venir à
l'émission connu qu'on était comestible
la belle isabelle en tout cas je vous
dis pour moi il s'est passé quelque
chose pour vous c'était très bien
[Applaudissements]